[Music]
guys what's up
good afternoon good morning good evening
um
yeah man
episode 12 121 i think
um
if it's not i don't care
i literally don't care if it's not i
don't care um
that's hilarious yeah man it's monday
we're feeling good
monday monday yeah we just took a cheeky
sip sip and i'm not gonna lie to you
it's hit me just the one it's actually
licked me over i think it's because the
pineapple juice has been fermenting in
the fridge as well so it created his own
alcohol base
and now i suck a double double dose
double doozy yeah yeah yeah so
guys i hope you're feeling fresh feeling
good feeling fine
um
and yeah man it's monday bruv all this i
hate mondays is is long
when you tune in and then smg's chilling
in yeah to be played exactly chilling
need to be played before we start
anything before we get anything going
we're gonna have to send you over to
patreon
we're gonna have to send you over from
the logo
over to patreon gang it's going on
clutch down there you know
the
the the powers that be don't want the
voices the real voices to be heard yeah
so we have to do this song and dance
over here on a monday in it we have to
give you guys a little something a
little sliver a little taste a little
taste on a monday to let you know that
we're about you and we love you um but
really we want you to head on over to
patreon to see what pops on a thursday
that's what's really yeah thursday's
aware is really really good really
thursdays are our fridays let's just say
that
tgit over here you get me
hashtag
tgit head on over there see what pops on
the thursday i'm not gonna give much
away
but it's that boogie yogi it is that
boogie it's that groovy roovy man come
on um so yeah if you like what you see
on a monday you're gonna love we see on
a thursday
and um it's patreon.com forward slash
shits and gigs um there should be a link
somewhere just follow over or type in
the url man whatever you need to do get
over there three pound a month 10p a day
run us the p man vibes support support
your boys
we need out of the rat race we do we
need out of the rat race we do because
the day we're out of the rat race
oh this is going to be exponential bro
we'll be in your hometown whenever
whenever whenever
yeah so head on over to patreon um
show your boys some love and enjoy the
extra content
on top of every thursday every thursday
there's ever been is also one there of
course you've got the entire record on
there so you can binge i know a couple
ma you man love to binge it go over
there and binge to your heart's content
you've got episodes on there episodes
episodes on there so yeah man some um
some
some prime moments some really memorable
moments over there on patreon that a lot
of you guys aren't privy to
um there was a time where i threw the
[ __ ] up the first time bella was ever on
the pod was on paper yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah man some good [ __ ]
over there you threw up jesus i felt
like death yeah remember i've never felt
so rough in my life remember damn
my brain won't work
damn my brain wasn't working
i was after sip sips no did we do sip
sips we didn't do sip sister or dude
went out and i went the night before fam
and mid-sentence i dipped off camera man
said i need to go
he said i need to go i threw the [ __ ] up
anyway guys head on over to patreon
enjoy yourself uh if you're watching on
youtube make sure you uh chirps a ting
in the comments
uh jump in there uh and let you let them
know while go on a couple guys one guy
messaged us last week
no one girl messaged us last week and
said guys it wasn't technically it
wasn't in the comments but she messaged
us and was like guys some guy slid in
their dms and was like hey i'm new here
in your hometown
i just want to see what's up i heard you
you you funk with the sng mandem let's
be friends she was like yeah i remember
that it's right over we loved that i
loved it sitting in the comments man
make this build bonds of relationships
community is strong man let's let's make
it everlasting let's make it everlasting
guys um click that thumbs up button
hop hop over there to the subscribe
button yeah give that
there's a bell next to it ding that bell
you need that notification man let me
you drink that notification weekend yeah
yeah week and week week in week out man
i don't miss it man um there are guys in
the construction there are guys in the
comments racing to be the first one to
see your video fam racing racing you
need to be there they're vex when
they're third
vex so yeah you know that same don is
always first or third and he's between
one two and three he's one to win threes
he wants with three
um but anyway
[ __ ] it now let's just go let's just
chat let's get into the episode let's
just go let's just go i've said enough
let's go let's go let's go let's go all
right fulfill me
today's today's fun fact of the day guys
um
where is i got here
right so
the 5 billion rubik's cube
how how a hungarian architect
built one of the best selling toys ever
obviously the rubik's cube
um so in 1974 erno rubick is his name
made the first rubik's cube or yeah
first rubik's cube and sold it and sold
them out of a small factory
demand increased in 1979 he signed and
distributed
he signed a distributing deal with a u.s
toy company 100 million rubik's cube
units were sold in the next three years
owner was making 30k a month in
royalties and over 100 million in the
process
lifetime sales include
450 million plus units sold
with five billion dollars in global
revenue from a rubik's cube bro bro
mum was an architect
to be fair i was an architect i thought
let me make
a game
let me have you ever actually tried a
rubik's cube i've tried but i've never
succeeded i know apparently there's a
there's an algorithm there's an
algorithm or like a chico for you to
succeed you have to go like down and
left down the left all the time or
something like that so there is i did it
not long ago because i was i was fed up
i just needed to know how you actually
do it
how anyone can do it like just figuring
out with their own brain it's one of
them things is to figure out with your
own brain without knowing there's any
algorithm you have to be a flat out
genius of course
you have to because when you actually go
on youtube in black because like i had
one and i was like [ __ ] let's just go
on youtube and get tutorial bro
the way they break it down into steps
it's like this is impossible to do
without this how does anyone do it
without this bro you have to like do a
couple things here and it's like all
right cool but you can't even just do it
any place you have to find like go to
the yellow side yeah and then
do the up down left up down left up down
left until there's one more yellow in
the top right corner once you've found
that yellow turn it to the red side and
do it up down left right up down left
right up down left right until there's
two here once there's that you do this
this this one
that's long it's extensive it's long bro
and i still [ __ ] up on the last point
i was doing it and it's the tutorial
still wasn't patterning me
i was one move away from completing the
whole thing
it wasn't patterning for me i was
excited i love the tick i've never done
one i've loved it i think i'm sure is it
justin bieber that knows how to do one
really i'm pr there's a celebrity that
can do it and i'm pretty sure there's a
celebrity that can do it either with his
eyes closed or on in a certain timeline
i.e one minute and also have you seen
there's a
there's an artist genius that makes
portraits from rubik's cubes have you
seen that on socials yes i have that is
insane have you seen the artists that
make portraits out of writing that
person's name yes i have ridiculous yes
i have ridiculous yes i'm [ __ ] out
ridiculous some people are too talented
in this world it doesn't make sense how
do you even figure stuff like that out
how do you bro i don't know i don't know
who's got that time that's the thing
who's got that time i don't i definitely
don't have that time i'm going to do a
portrait of [ __ ] bradley cooper out
of rubbish cubes all right and bradley
cooper or just writing bradley cooper a
gazillion times
it's nice
people have talent and time and i have
neither
um speaking of talent
foo head hear me i've been listening to
music today ah on the drive up uh i was
listening to music like
there's a difference between hearing
music and listening to music and i
realized that today spud me yes i
completely agree i realized that i
completely agree because
what brought out to me was um
i realized
i've got a few points to make okay let's
just buckle up yeah i'm here for stuff
like this first of all
tick-tock is
killing music
but also
pushing it okay i agree
i listened to um
i
was reminded by this initially
when we were on holiday the other week
and we were in the the sushi restaurant
and the dj was going off yeah yeah yeah
and he played the doji cat streets yes
which is the silhouette trend on
tick-tock yes
that song's a [ __ ] banger food
that song is an absolute banger of
course it is but i only really ever
heard it i saw it on tiktok before i
ever heard it properly okay so by the
time already heard it properly i was
[ __ ] sick of it
and you just relate it to this trend on
tick tock and you write it off as an
actual piece of art yeah it's it's not
art it's just a trick it's just a
trainer yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
obviously that was like a year ago
however long ago the silhouette
challenge was um
so it randomly because i have that album
on my apple music and i'm pretty sure
i'm the one that pushed you on that
album you were i'm pretty sure you are
you are you are um because i used to
listen to is juicy on that album yeah i
was listening to juicy anyway but then
you put me on the album album's fire the
album's fire and then um
yeah streets has never popped up on my
shuffle i always just do shuffle
it's never popped up until like
literally
about two days after we came back from
holiday and we heard it in the
restaurant
it came up
volume up up up the bass
it's a banger bro the bass
banger
fam
and i was thinking this song's a [ __ ]
tune bro
and i wrote it off because tick tock
just is destroying it for me yeah i
can't handle it anymore it's just
annoying and there's a few that are
circling right now that i i've said like
if this song wasn't on tick tock it
would slap
if i just stumbled across this song
it'll be my favorite song ever yeah yeah
but it's just it's never going to happen
now because it's tick-tock because it
sticks out
but the song would never be popular if
it wasn't for tick-tock so it's just
like as i love page 22.
yeah yeah so it's either like you can be
popular but no one's going to rate your
musical talent
but you'll you'll make money millions of
it you'll make money yeah um
so today i was listening to a music bro
and like the reason why i said about the
you can hear music without listening to
it
is there's um
cleo soul
has got uh album out at the minute okay
it came out a few weeks ago okay
three separate people messaged me about
this album okay when it dropped
uh and i was like gang i love glitter
bang i'm on it and um
i tried to listen to it when i wasn't in
the mood to listen i was just in the
mood to hear to hear i want to hear
music i don't want to listen to anything
yeah yeah and bro i tried to listen to
it three separate occasions and i was
like this is not that good it's not the
vibe yeah everyone's talking about how
great is this i'm not feeling it like it
just it's just not for me yeah bro
slapped it on today
yeah bangs yeah it
bangs so today i was listening to
streets
reeled that up about so in this three
hour drive from my house to here yeah
streets got slapped about seven times
yeah
um
clear soul went back to front
uh saved a few from there that i i love
there's one song there called music
oh
it's a banger yeah oh food it's a banger
um
what other one was i listening to
the one that you put me on the wizkid
one
um
steady banger
fan banger oh what today you never need
to worry family are you mad that's the
bar i was just thinking of
that's the bar is literally just do you
know what he says do you know so he says
yeah do you know what that means no that
means money is here you don't need to
worry about it exactly i had no idea
exactly what to do i'm just saying it
would you do you never have to worry
from
when you played that the other week yeah
i didn't i stopped in my truck so what
is this
what is this this is bangs
so steady got slapped about nine times
um
and
second
man he's spitting
he's talking some [ __ ] he's talking he's
in he's feeling he's fantastic he lives
in his feet you know he's he knows he
[ __ ] up and he just needs to confess
sorry
i'm sorry babes i [ __ ] up i was out of
[ __ ] fans i don't know what i was
doing
i'm 10 years in the game but i'm only
human he's interested in humans if you
saw the dms i get
i'm only human i can only say no so many
times
and when you found out i got a kid
i can only imagine what your friend said
fam
i can only imagine what your friend said
that's such a bad on people i don't
think people get he's a lyricist i can
only imagine what your friend said bro
well your girl said about that because
he knows your brethrens speak everything
before you've had a chance to process a
woman when she gets like that i'm coming
to you as a woman message yeah and she
turns to her girls her girls will run
you into the ground before you guys even
had a chance to process it
look like you could be tom dick or harry
they'll run you to the ground your
girlfriend's friends want you dead 100
that's the god's honest truth 100
all girlfriends want is
single girlfriends
you know what i mean yeah all girls want
is all their friends to be single they
want them to have a man and they want
all their friends single that's all they
want from so anytime you [ __ ] up that
you're out you're out big man you're out
single babies he's not worth it he's not
worth it let's go out
[ __ ] i'll get you dick tonight tonight
you'll forget about him no that's what
they want it's disgusting
it's disgusting um
i'm just gonna give a little bit of love
to our boys over at
manscapes you know the vibes
so
obviously it's october we've got that
spooky yuki
that spooky uku halloween season man are
booking that alton towers ahead of
schedule they want to hit the maze
yeah
[Music]
fam
before my skate came along every friday
afternoon was a spooky for me
found this thing
[Music]
just to get a little bit of aesthetic
just to get that extra length
blood oh frankenstein's monster bro just
to get a little bit of love when i was
uh when i was a young man before
manscape approached us and said jump on
board test the product that's the
product i've got the products here fam i
just thought it was butcher season
every friday afternoon was butcher
season for me i just thought that was
part of the process
but now man they came along and said it
doesn't have to be this way it just
doesn't it it really doesn't it just
really doesn't literally doesn't have to
be that way and i said what do you mean
it's like here's the alternative here's
the alternative i'm smooth and i said
yeah you smooth but you bleed that's the
price you pay
for the long schlong yeah they said no
no no no not with that you've been doing
it backwards not with our 4.0 and they
said here yeah they literally said they
say kikide dympheno
eta represents
man like it rocks
[Laughter]
wow we're drunk
that is hilarious i've not heard that
song in a decade surely
[Laughter]
such a uni track right oh that's
hilarious so guys they they they pulled
up and they first said here's the
generation three
it was fantastic i can't lie it did the
[ __ ] it did it it did what i needed to
do it literally did what it needed to do
um i had i had very few critiques but i
had
we gave him some notes and
we said
critique is a strong word but here's
some notes yeah and they said us
so they went back into the lab and the
boys came back with the performance
thank you very much they went back into
the dungeon
and they literally came out with
frankenstein's monster 4.0.0 man
and can i say guys it is everything we
gave him notes about
everything and more was more than we
could ever dream of so sleek he's so
sleek so smooth the battery lasts
forever as well bro
ah guys if you want to jump on
you head on over to manscape.com
um
the code you want to use is sng sierra
november golf sierra november golf and
you can get yourself 20 off
and free shipping wherever you are in
the world okay
so guys head on over enjoy yourself get
that long schlong without x
and um
yeah let's get back to the episode man
okay there you go fam do you remember
when we were in uni yeah sometimes in
lectures there'd be a random speaker and
the lecturer will be like guys at the
end if you can just give five minutes to
a guest and they're going to come in and
they're going to talk to you about
cruise ship trips
do you remember
they're going to talk to you about ski
trips and you're going to stay in a
lodge yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
i always used to give them the time yeah
but i can't afford this yeah i'll never
be able to afford this yeah uni days uni
days i can't i can barely afford to eat
i can barely afford to eat and put
clothes on my back these times i'm
topping up my shower gel with water and
giving it a quick
i can never afford that we didn't have
that wasteland we did wasteland travel
that wasteland trouble they've come
they've come a long way they've come to
hook you man up now if they would have
hit us up and just said yo run that
quick game
you can get this you can get this thing
for free you can win a couple things if
they came in the lecture room and said
yeah i know what the budget's saying in
uni yeah you men are a bit skinny
look if you can afford it gang splash
that yeah you men in the back you dark
skins in the back follow the link below
yeah follow the link play a game you
know snake snake retreating retro tigger
yeah of course i don't know knock your
third every 10 days yeah yeah yeah i
know that get yourself on that
leaderboard level two level three
you could you could pattern this for
free you could pattern a little ski trip
will you make a pattern this for free of
course you just hear whispers
is it and i'm like but miss
miss i don't have a ski ball i don't
have a board or skis or the poles or
nothing and he said bet bet you could
win that two you can win that too you
could win that too
okay okay cool so
guys if you like us times are hard
jump in the link
head on over to wastelandtravel.com yeah
mom these man will hook you up with
their game get yourself on that lead
board look out for your boys on there
where's the top scorers
we're on there we had a little dabble
um but head on over and uh grab yourself
an opportunity to to get yourself on the
slopes
that black ice
it could be yours you know it could be
yours it could be you can have it all
you could have you gotta pay a cent so
um head on over wastelandtravel.com and
uh enjoy yourself yeah man have fun win
some prizes but yeah man oh my god i've
been listening to music today i'm very
jealous of you purely because this is
something i've always wanted to do in
terms of
finding new music purely because i i
lift i listen to music all the time i
try to listen to music all the time but
the only times i do get to listen to
music
are
either in the gym
or walking to and from work or to and
fro somewhere else
sometimes at home yes but we tend to
listen to the same stuff because we're
trying to find a vibe as opposed to
trying to find something new yeah yeah
so that's why i envy you because you
drive a lot you've got the opportunity
to just like reel off new music if i'm
in a gym i don't want to listen to new
music
i want to hear [ __ ] that would get me
pumped and hyped and blah blah so i'm
going to play stuff that i already know
you just want to hear noise i just want
to hear noise that's a i want to hear
something exactly yeah so i don't really
have the opportunity to listen to music
so i'm jealous of you bro the best
podcasts i've ever listened to and the
best music i've ever listened to are on
long ass [ __ ] drivers i'm not
surprised bro because like especially
like podcasts and stuff because like joe
rogan is a good one where he'll have
funny people on there and they'll also
have like really interesting people in
there like archaeologists and like
um
biochemists and all this stuff and a lot
of the time bro when i'm running to the
shop i can't be asked to listen to an
archaeologist's chat yeah yeah but
there's been times i've been on the way
back from manchester and it could be
like one o'clock in the morning
and i'm not like sleepy or anything like
that and i'm like let me just put this
on yeah and bro some of the stuff i've
learned on there you're like wow yeah
and that was exactly the same with the
music today it's like i remember i was
in the middle lane
bombing down i was doing like 90.
bombing down the m6
i had i was leaning my face like that
and i was driving like that
and bro for some reason the music hit me
and i wasn't even listening to that
clear soul album because i knew i was
processing music different because
steady got wrapped up like nine times
i'm not joking yeah yeah i heard all of
it yeah yeah all of it yeah i was like
today and listen i need to listen to
this clip it's all over yeah because i
reckon it's gonna it's gonna hit me
today um
and bro
it made me feel like how can music how
can people make this
like she's got a couple songs on there
that are like
the lyrics are banging the vibes banging
but she's got songs in there that are
like reminiscent of like old motown
songs okay like um like the supremes
okay or like some oh diana ross like
from the 50s okay and you're like she's
done that and then she's put her own
spin on it and the lyrics are
impactful and she's all done that and
the way she's even like
doing the tempo with her notes
just like the beat that not even the
beat obviously you've got the
instrumentals and stuff like that but
even the rhythm that she's spitting out
yeah it's like that's it's so completely
unique because it doesn't
fit typically to what's happening with
that music but it works perfectly
because she's decided to do it okay and
you're like
why is your brain on yeah how have you
patterned this what mood were you in
that day where you were like i'm just
gonna do it this way yeah
and then everyone's like [ __ ] hell
that's sick yeah [ __ ] hell that's it
[ __ ] hell they're sick keep going
bro and then you think ra you can tell
why people like fall in love with like
artists yeah
regardless of what they look like yeah
except for that because you think
your brain's on a different yeah you
work differently still you work
differently like you're a genius in your
own way and that's why like um
i like when
obviously watching a lot of anime they
call people geniuses
and a lot of time that has nothing to do
with academics whereas in like in our
culture if you're a genius you're just
smart academically yeah of course but
like in like
asian culture they call you a genius
because you're just a prodigy or
whatever it is that you do yeah um and i
like that i've always liked that because
when you listen to this clear soul album
bro some of the stuff you think oh this
[ __ ] is a genius yeah what's the album
called mother
cool fam there's a couple tracks on
there you think this [ __ ] is a genius
and that's just how it is say no more i
need to do better that's how i feel
about like yeah yeah yeah comedy and
stuff like that as well when you see
like certain stamp stand ups and stuff
you think this motherfucker's a genius
how did
what how is your brain working like this
it doesn't make sense
dave chappelle it doesn't make sense
speaking of you know he's got a new
thing coming out yes i do someone put it
on
i think someone posted it or something
yeah by the time this episode comes out
it would have already been out yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's called bummer we've seen
it yeah coming soon bro cannot wait i
know you that's as soon as i saw it i
was like he's performing in the uk this
month is it i'm vex about it i can't go
where where and when he's here manny
when
uh
this week or next week really yeah
i need to have a look have a look i need
to see if you can grab something last
minute yeah he's hearing my he's in
london as well okay uh he might be in
birmingham but fam yeah he's about okay
remind me after this episode yeah yeah
yeah i didn't even know he was doing it
oh yeah yeah i only found out because a
comedian a uk comedian that i follow
posted on his story the other day that
was like i've got two tickets to see
dave chappelle like in two weeks uh i
can't go so like message me and i'll
give you the
the tickets at the price i paid for them
i was thinking what are you talking
about
you're giving
where are they vegas
like i don't get it haven't i looked i
couldn't believe it gang
and um
lastly speaking of art
fam
tell me you've watched squid game oh one
i'm not finished have you finished yeah
okay
the reason why i knew you you've watched
it is because you've not spoken about it
not spoke we're not messaging each other
nothing about i think i'm on episode
seven and i think there's what nine
episodes nine episodes yeah so i'm too
behind
bro
series
series series i love i love the fact
that it's korean as well because it
reminded me of watching parasite because
parasites koreans these [ __ ]
make
entertaining television broski
they take
what's the word i'm looking for
they push the boundary and they push the
border to the next level and they don't
compromise on storytelling either the
storytelling is fantastic everyone has
their background everyone has this
nothing is rushed
it's not rushed whatever and i'm still
got two apps to watch nothing is rushed
their pacing is fantastic what's his
mate what's the main guy's name jihan i
think yeah
he's a [ __ ] gambler that the first
episode obviously the first version
where you have to find out about it no
man would gamble on anything just to
make a better picture oh i was vexed
was vex bro yeah he's a gambling addict
it's a great anyone that's not watched
squid games on netflix i don't know what
you're waiting for bro i don't know jump
the [ __ ] on squid game and then i was
really happy about how popular it was
because
i've been watching korean [ __ ] for years
not loads bearing in mind but
a few of my favorite things ever are
coincidentally korean okay like because
i remember when i watched i've i've been
spreading the word on old boy
since i was like that's on netflix now i
think the original or
amazon prime i don't know i don't know
if there's an original remake but i've
seen all this play on one of these
services the there is i think it might
be amazon prime
um
there's the remake the american one
which i haven't seen okay we've um oh
what's his name josh brolin okay josh
brolin is the main character actor um
actor he's the main character in that
one i haven't seen it and i refuse to
watch it okay
you if anyone's interested in watching
old boy do not watch the josh brolin one
i love just rolling but i already know
it's not as good as the as the original
bro
when you say pushing boundaries yeah the
twist in this film has the best plot
twist of any movie i've ever seen ever
in my life damn old boy is one of the
best movies i've ever seen from i've
seen thousands of movies
i've seen
old boy is one of the best movies of all
time
it's [ __ ] amazing
i'm i'm on it i remember you talking to
me about a time ago and i remember you
telling me the plot of it
but
i want to say it's got something to do
with
is a guy like locked in a room fam yeah
so i'll give you the premise yeah if
anyone's watching and i would not so a
lot of time i just end up spoiling it i
won't spoil this at all because it's so
good everyone has to watch the original
boy
um
so the premise is there's a korean guy
living his life
and um
he basically gets kidnapped and locked
in a room for [ __ ] years and he has
no idea why he gets locked in a room
and every now and again they'll gas him
put him to sleep and they'll like give
him a haircut change his clothes
maybe put a new tv in his room or
whatever and um he's just locked in this
room for years and years and years and
he has no idea why i'm
we're talking 10 plus years wow and he's
got a tv in there
so he knows what's going on in the world
yeah yeah and um he gets delivered food
and stuff
but he has no idea why and there'll
always be like a member of staff that
will just like put a tray of food under
the table and he'll be banging on the
door like
why the [ __ ] am i here what's going on
yeah they'll ignore him so eventually
just stops and all he does in this time
is
exercise
that's the first thing i was thinking of
exercise and learns how to fight okay so
he learns how to fight watches like kung
fu movies and stuff like that and like
um
he draws this like
silhouette on the wall to practice yeah
[ __ ]
learns how to fight and just [ __ ]
exercise that's all he does for years
and years and years eventually they just
let him out into the world
they gas him put him in a briefcase
chuck him on on the roof of like this
skyscraper and then he just hops out the
briefcase when he wakes up
and it's like cool so his mission for
the whole movie from when he gets let
out of this room is to find out why the
[ __ ] he got put in this room he goes on
a mission to find out why
and it just the story develops from
there
it's [ __ ]
amazing
it's [ __ ] the stuff
and
if that wasn't juicy enough the twist
that they throw in there yeah oh my god
oh my it's the best i've seen it at
least five times oh gang i love old boy
so old boy was like the first my first
experience to like korean cinema okay
and i was like wow and i've been
preaching that since forever
best movie best movie yeah and then um
there's another one there's a horror-ish
movie i've seen called
the train to busan
that's
isn't that directed by the same guy that
directed parasite maybe i think it is
because
every time when i watched parasite one
of my favorite movies i've ever watched
i
googled him and seen what other stuff
he's done he's done the train to busan i
believe yeah and he's also done
um
what's the one that's an adaptation
that's currently on netflix
uh it's a train thing that's snow
piercer
adaptation as a series and i think it's
the same brother okay yeah i think he's
not trained to be you might be right
yeah i think here i think he's on there
as well because that actually sounds
familiar yeah um he's done quite a few
and yeah obviously i love parasite as
well parasite was amazing and i'm sure
there's something else of there's a
couple other things i've watched that
are korean that are just so good so when
squid game popped i originally for some
reason i thought squid game was japanese
same same and i was watching it for like
two three minutes and i was like these
man ain't speaking japanese this is
[ __ ] korean as soon as i clocked it
was korean i was like this show's gonna
pop yeah because these korean man know
what they're doing they push boundaries
when it comes to life or death or when
it comes to making a choice when it
comes to if money is involved oh bro it
might like it reminded me of parasite
pure because one is north korean and two
it just depicts how you can go from
ranks to riches potentially and
the things you have to do bro the things
you have to do
in that show a cake
it's literally
it is so like relevant as well because
everyone always talks about their like
would you do this for this much money
this much money yeah yeah and these men
are like
yeah i'll do it so these might like do
it then do it then do it then show me
you can do it how much are you willing
to go through for this amount of money
madness bro the ending is bragging
there's a twist in there as well banging
i can't wait to finish it because i've
been watching like i think the first day
i watched it was like two three days ago
i we watched maybe
two i think i watched maybe four reps
next day i watched two next day i
watched like one or so so i need to i
think i might watch it finish it off
today or tomorrow bro it bangs
bangs and the thing is even before
anything juicy happens
it goes to show like the pacing and the
detail they've put in like the acting
and stuff like that you're hooked like
immediate of course
immediately you're hooked i don't know
what it is i love the acting in it bro
it's so good jihan is a character he's a
charac and you can also tell that he is
as funny as he is and as um
as much of of a gambler he is he's also
a quick thinker slash what's the word
i'm looking for he's also the one that
thinks with common sense yeah so
there were a time there were times where
the tug of war scene for example
he was at the front
and he was panicking oh he was shook
panicking and obviously one of the
others was like let's try this yeah
other guys were like no no no he's like
[ __ ] let's just try it you don't know
yeah so he's like the reasonable one
he's the reasonable thinker yeah yeah
regardless of what else you see or how
else regardless of how else the
directors are trying to depict him you
know he's a reasonable thinker because
he's just he's just too quick good on
the job he's too good on the job 100
yeah bro he was
[ __ ] i was intense that tug of war
that tugger was [ __ ] intense
wow wow
intense yeah mom that yeah i hate that
yeah the bait the baby at baby babe babe
i don't know babe yeah she's trying to
survive
she's trying to survive she's trying to
survive the last where i'm up to was the
last game was
soon as you took a breath i knew it was
marbles no balls bro tell me you didn't
want to cry fat bro the my man that um
dupes the
the pakistani bread are he's going to
hell hell fire bro he's going to hell
and he was the anger he's a strong
[ __ ] in the first in the second
episode when he grabbed
him and jim was like don't move cuz
don't move or i'm eliminated fam man
grabbed him held him tight didn't swear
yeah fam
ali my guy ali that's his name ali oh
bro bro broke my [ __ ] heart and the
old brother number one
number one bamboo
fan be my ganboo a man knew what was
going on all along
family
when he was like
do you think it's okay yeah when he said
put all your marbles in he said that's
crazy at all why would i do that why
would you trick me do you think it's
okay to trick me the whole time
man took her breath i was crying man
took a breath
the first bit where he was like oh what
did you say
and i was like even man changed it the
thing is as well it's so great that like
it's one of the ones that you you put
yourself in that situation and you're
like i would have done the same same
thing you have to you have to regardless
how much it breaks your literally fight
or flight you haven't got a choice oh
she's banging him he's i'm not dying
here this shows his boundaries 100
100 oh it makes you feel like you're in
the game bro yes 100 wow when they had
the
scrap
the first scrap
lights out
and the guards knew it was gone of
course yeah yeah yeah yeah you knew what
was going on yeah yeah oh my god they
they've got the human psyche down to a
tv
man said there's going to be a fight
tonight of course it's okay how do you
know and they just no it just popped off
we've done this game many a time
i know how this team goes i love how
they have to either pick a partner or do
this or do that before they find out
what the game is because they're trying
to just oh it's it's
as soon as they said pick a partner i
already knew it already you knew it i
already knew i was like come on boys
come on you know but anyway i don't want
to spoil it for you guys anyone who
hasn't seen this quick game get your
[ __ ] i've actually got a fact this is a
mid ep fun fact i've got a fact as well
but god squid about squid probably the
same thing go on so
um i follow this thing on instagram that
just gives me random facts about random
shows and different things here that's
why i got the simpsons one from that we
did a few episodes ago
um so squid games created by
huang dong-hyuk same fact i've got yeah
wrote this show in 2009 yeah in fact 12
years ago
but was rejected by the studios for 10
years
he once had to stop writing the script
sell his laptop for 635 due to money
struggles today it's the number one show
in 90 plus countries and set to become
the most watched show on netflix history
that's insane so yeah if you guys think
we're chatting [ __ ] these are the facts
bro you guys need to watch this show you
guys need to watch this show man wrote
the show tried to sell it to anyone that
would have it and man said get away get
away i'm not interested it sounds [ __ ]
the thing is that it's not even
necessarily sounding [ __ ] i think at the
time it was too gruesome and i think
there's a bit more notes to it because
obviously like we said they pushed the
boundaries in this show they pushed the
boundaries in the show so i think back
then in 2009 or whatever and up until
now
it people just went on it people just
weren't on it and obviously netflix they
pushed the budget as well because they
showed they put anything on there oh
netflix or right or dies anything's on
netflix so yeah it's um
and it's gonna be the what the most shot
what show in netflix history netflix
history wow
history
squid games i remember it is sick as
well because obviously i saw it and it
was one of the ones where i was gonna
watch it eventually yeah but i was in no
rush to watch it this is before no no
one had posted about it nothing same and
you know what it says like oh number one
in the uk or whatever fam three days in
a row this [ __ ] was number one
in the uk and i remember thinking that's
impossible fam i saw when we were in
mykonos is when i saw it because of it
in our rooms you had them tvs in our
room so i saw squid games on there and i
was thinking it was number one already
really this was in greece
it was number one number one for weeks i
saw the trailer but it doesn't give you
much in the trailer so i was like i
don't really know what this is yeah
because a lot of the time they show you
that maze where they're walking around
in their colorful that colorful room
that's all they showed that much i was
thinking i can't really understand what
this is so i paid no attention to it
when i came back or when we came back
rather i saw it again on netflix i'm
thinking okay then i've seen it all over
socials fam i saw memes i saw guesses as
soon as i got on tick tock i don't want
to read anything about it if i close my
eyes on tick tock um scroll up every
third scroll i would hear
that red light green light scroll scroll
scroll
[Music]
episode one was a great introduction to
played games great the old man was
having a bubble
squid game's great i knew it was gonna
pop because
with the hop no whole like number one in
the uk thing yeah yeah yeah
people in the uk if unless you're used
to watching anime yeah people write off
subtitles of course so quick of course
so quickly of course so when i kept
saying it was number one i was thinking
how are people not writing this off
because i'll happily watch it yeah like
i'm used to this yeah this is back when
i thought it was japanese as well so i
was like i'm hella definitely watching
this this is mine for me yeah i was
thinking most people aren't into this
kind of stuff most people don't check
for subtitles then again a lot
well i don't know but i would like to
believe some people or a lot of people
may have just changed the audio
subtitles to dub to dubs oh no because
when you watch money heist when you
watch money heist normally it's
automatically dubbed really it's
automatically dubbed time for that you
have to change it back to the original
because it's spanish you have to change
it back to the original [ __ ] money house
is originally dubbed
nah netflix need to fix that yeah don't
originally dub my [ __ ]
speaking of money heist james from
season five there's it's a two-part
thing season five
it's five reps and i don't know how many
ups the second part is going to be
but bro adrenaline in every
episode lewis messaged me that no we
were in the gym the other week and he
was like get on money ice bro and i was
like food won't shut up about my bro
money i know we spoke about it before
like money has a great thing and he was
like oh you said our prison break is
this family
money heist doesn't let up there's
action
action
james i'm not kidding fair play i'm not
kidding fair play
i was the only reason i watched speed
games because i was looking for money
heist oh gang and i was thinking i can't
ignore this thing anymore it's just
popping up too often i'm gonna have to
watch it and it bodes well with when
we'll talk about geniuses obviously you
talk about genius academically money
heist the professor is a literal genius
gang okay cool
he thinks of every possible outcome gang
all right i'm here for it genius james
i'll jump on money heist you have to
okay i will officially do it next time
i'm here i would have seen at least a
couple of episodes
all right cool 100
speaking of
quick
anime plug okay tokyo revenges
okay jump the [ __ ] on okay jump the [ __ ]
on okay tokyo revenges okay is back give
you a synopsis
so did you ever watch erased
yes you told me about it [ __ ] anime
13 episodes of pure addiction bro
wow
what an anime
one of the first
non-fighting animes that blew my mind
yeah it's like definitely then erased
yeah yeah yeah bro together avengers is
similar to that okay similar to that
very similar premise in terms of um
basically is a guy
living his life he's 25 years old i
think 25 26.
and he's just a slug of a man slug of a
man and nothing's going right for him
and then um he reads on the news that
his high school girlfriend's been
murdered
by this gang oh wow um
and he realizes that
um
obviously that was his high school
girlfriend and he was aware of that gang
when he was in like middle school that
gang were there then but they weren't
like an organized tokyo gang back there
yeah they were just they were just like
a middle school gang they were just like
these road man just they were just road
men yeah basically long story short yeah
long story short they were just road men
um
so random he's at the train station
thinking about it one day
and he falls onto the train tracks gets
hit by a train
and it sends him back in
time to when he was in middle school to
when he was still going out with that
girl but he still has the cognitive
knowledge of but he knows he he's
actually a 26 year old man
so it's kind of similar to similar to
that so basically his mission is like
cool if i make changes now like i can
stop her from ever dying like 12 years
in the future so basically his power is
to they find out because he goes back
and forth for cup times and he finds out
his power is to go 12 ye exactly 12
years to the day
in the past so if he goes back to
present
chills for three days then goes back
it'll be three days ahead yeah so back
in time
his
like when he's not in that body making
these changes
the three days that he's back in the
present time he's still living his
normal life like back in time you know
what i mean so his teenager self is
still living it so sometimes he'll go
back in time and he'll be in a random
situation yeah okay bro
and i haven't finished it yet
i'm not up to date yet i think there's
20 something okay and i'm like on
episode 18 or something okay
who had okay some of the twists and
turns
they take you in a direction you're
never going to expect for it
they take your addiction you're never
ever going to expect them for it oh it's
a great anime do you know what i i i
i feel like if i say i'll spoil the
shows about squid games again but i'll
spoil the show all right
i
yeah they deserve on this one they
deserve better the fans deserve to if
they haven't seen it they deserve to not
have it spoiled yeah yeah so great
that's incredible right yeah i've got a
question um
yeah okay cool so we spoke about it very
briefly in the car
but you seem to be on the front lines of
this okay fan brexit is actually brexit
in
and i need to understand what's going on
with the supply chain
actually need to understand
brexit is really brexit i've gone into
shops and there's just
everything is scarce there's nothing
there's nothing there it's actually a
concern there's nothing there bro like i
said to you as well like work there's
there's cutlery missing bro
there's cutlery and crockery missing and
crockery we just don't have enough
supplies some days it makes no sense
nah it makes no sense because a lot of
the things we get are from overseas of
course
they're just not shipping it
they're just not shipping it nah that
can't run
fam when these man went to vote
and it was leave or stay yeah someone
needed to educate this man we're a tiny
little island in the middle of nowhere
no
we're smaller than the nowhere
oh let's get the shot at me there's a
marker just fell off
we need that supply chain we do we need
that we can't survive without it fam
we're so small and insignificant in the
middle of the ocean with this tiny
little dot in the middle of the ocean
these men are chilling chilling bro
chilling fam someone needs to run up to
to switzerland to say brussels wherever
they do it take us back
please
take us please i think this was in
geneva i think that's where they do the
summits
wherever they do it take us back that
that's something what g15 or whatever
it's called fam g8 g7 i don't know what
they need to do boris needs to grovel
say fam we ain't had evian in months
and i'm not joking i've actually not
seen everyone in chops big man
every
few days i buy a six pack of 1.5 liter
bottles of evian
i've been doing that for years
i don't mess around bro last week i had
to get buxton
buxton vex
live it
live it the plastic they use in boxing
you try and [ __ ] do it and it spills
scarce as [ __ ] i've been drinking ultra
paradise which is this lime green color
thing it's [ __ ] [ __ ] flavor it's my
least favorite flavor of monster oh the
whites are scarce as [ __ ] damn bro i'm
pissed off bro i'm pissed off petrol is
a whole different story petrol is a
whole different story you might have
been going through it
[ __ ] nowadays um but it vexes me
because uh not to get political because
obviously there's a million reasons but
like
back in the back when we were voting not
uh people voted here and stayed like
some of their justifications were so
annoying like in terms of like our
stealing jobs and all this stuff did you
know there's a there's an actual fact
this is a fact
obviously now that people are realizing
about this lorry driver situation
like big mounting no one's going to
start being a lorry driver
no one is because where's the longevity
in that job in that career choice
where's the longevity in that
and like
did you know my brother told me this the
other day there are more job vacancies
currently like in the uk yeah than there
ever have been really since the
beginning of time really so people talk
about can't get job can't get up there
are more job vacancies than there ever
have been people can't get the staff to
fill their job positions
and then
they're trying to think of incentives to
get people in these jobs yeah and one of
the incentives is to increase the wage
yeah
but that doesn't solve the problem yeah
because all that happens is if i'm a
receptionist over here and this company
is increasing their wage because they
can't find a receptionist and their wage
is above my wage i move from this
receptionist job to this receptionist
there's not a brand new receptionist
just come fresh out of college getting
this job i've already got an experience
as a receptionist i'm going to get a
higher paying receptionist job and now
my old job has a vacancy as a
receptionist job that they can't feel so
then they increase the wage and then
another reception is from over here
people just jump ship jump ship and then
not the the vacancies aren't being
filled people are just moving from one
place to another
and like people talk about oh we can't
find like can't get a job can't get a
job you can get a job
very easily
it's just that no one wants those jobs
obviously reception is different that
was just an example a lot of people want
to be receptionists but yeah like
their jobs are available family just
people don't want them
or they're not qualified for them and
they don't want to get caught people
aren't willing to take like the plunge
to like right
let me go back and do my gcc's real
quick you can do it online for [ __ ]
sake can you well you can do a lot of
[ __ ] online like you need to go back and
do your gcc's bro you just need to
like send an email to the governing body
or whatever and say i need to retake
this and i'm like call your exams on
this day
you pay a certain fee they'll send you
the books bro quick tangent if you had
to do maths english since gcse signs
today no revision nine do you think
you'll pass
i [ __ ] hope so i doubt it
manta man i [ __ ] hope so but i doubt
it i think i would smash english i was
just about to say i think me and english
will get along yeah i'm very good at
maths but sometimes when it comes to
like for example long division right
i knew how to do it i've not done it in
a decade bro i don't care about it so
can i do it again i don't know
maths to me is like naruto hand signs
it's not about learning it you just need
to remember yeah yeah yeah yeah and if
you miss up a sequence your answer ain't
gonna pattern right and you don't know
where you went wrong
what's that what's that theory is it was
it not pythagoras theorem there wasn't
pythagoras there was one thing i think
this was in like a level maths
where
you had like a square root thing and it
was plus minus like 2b
all over it was long bro i don't know
bro it was like four a b plus minus this
th someone knows what i'm talking about
i don't know what for the life means
that's
yeah i think it was like a1 or a2 i
don't know
it was all over like it was weird bro
and if you got that like you said like
the jitsu hand sign if you got that
formula wrong your whole thing is wrong
yeah your whole thing is wrong you don't
know where you've gone wrong because you
just don't remember that formula yeah
but yeah uh math sometimes
science i think i don't know if i'd pass
science
i don't know i don't know brian i
remember in um
human biology a level
part we did like our teacher he was good
he was a good egg he used to give us
like quizzes every week
which was good yeah because you just you
needed to pay attention fab there was
one you had to like
label every part of like a chromosome or
something oh man there's like 20
different bits and you have to and
obviously there's an arrow pointing what
is this what is this what is this what
is this you have to write out it's like
a chromosome or some kind of cell i
can't remember
fam
i remember
he bust through one time as he was
marking them because we had two human
biology teachers okay
and alternating weeks we'd have each one
so while we were in uh one woman's he
was marking our ones from this week's
quiz last week's quiz he bust through
the doors where's james where's james i
was like [ __ ] hell yeah and he was
like he came over shook my hand it was
like you're the only one that got the
chromosome question right okay i guess
the whole thing
i guessed the whole thing bro man my
teacher couldn't come into another class
and shout where's fooha
my heart would leave my chest james bro
and i was a slacker in that
i guessed the whole thing and i
remembered from then i was thinking he
thinks i know [ __ ] yeah when i don't
know [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so he's looking
at you next week now oh 100 looking at
you next week that was question one uh
so what he would do was mark quit
everyone's question why not mark
everyone's question too yeah so he
thinks james he's the [ __ ] yeah
until he gets to question two yeah so he
didn't come in again to shake my hand
let's just say that
i got like a [ __ ] e for the whole
quiz but the question won a pattern yeah
i guess the whole thing and i was
thinking this whole school that was when
the light bulb pretty much this whole
school [ __ ] is [ __ ] bro ain't about
like knowing [ __ ] it's about remembering
stuff because i just guessed
and i got it right and he thinks i'm a
[ __ ] genius now because no one else
in this class that people are a lot
smarter than me yeah didn't get it and i
got it and i just [ __ ] guessed it bro
um
but yeah to bring it back to what we
were talking about
bro
the brexit thing's long i don't know how
it's going to get solved it is because i
have no idea we need lorry drivers
they're paying like 60 70 bags for lorry
drivers now you know that might have 60
70 bags i've heard to drive a hdv fam
someone jump in that truck
someone do it because i need monster and
i need everyone
it's not a joke getting my stuff back
fam we went to the co-op before this
baron it was not in there
baron it was barely water in there
there was hardly anything in there i
couldn't believe it and you realize it
made me realize how the other day
actually how many lorry drivers there
actually must be because if you actually
go into like i saw a tesco truck the
other day driving past me i was just
thinking about this whole lorry driver
situation and one tesco drug looking at
the size of it and i was looking at it
and i was thinking
for like a big tesco
that truck probably only covers the
[ __ ] meat yeah
like how big that truck is and then you
actually think how much is like stock is
in a [ __ ] tesco yeah i was thinking
this probably covers just the meat yeah
for one shot yeah for this week yeah
i was thinking [ __ ] hell there was a
lot of drivers out there
we're losing it
open the borders
open the borders let them do what they
want they need to do big man run me the
evion
i can't be stuck with boxed buxton and
[ __ ] highland springs for the rest of
the years and yeah moving forward i
wasn't kidding i don't know how this is
gonna go from this petrol thing it's
different oh i've never seen it
literally never seen anything like it
of course not
literally there's never been anything
like it that's why it makes no sense
britain since forever we did you know at
one point um
britain
owned 25
of the world's population
damn i knew they owned a lob i didn't
know 25 25
wow
we ran more of the world than genghis
khan did
back in his day he ran like 24 or 22 or
some of that
we were running 25
of the world bro back in the day
this has never happened before wow
time's up people forgot
yeah and back in them times no there's
british impacting we're not living in
them times
these men in portugal will lock us off
without us without a blink of an eye
family ran up in there said we want out
we didn't know what we were saying
jesus
we didn't know what we were saying
the rest of the world said good luck
with that
now we're struggling at it
can't fill up my car to to save my life
this is just the beginning it's
literally just the beginning you ain't
even got knives and forks at work
running low bro everyone's running low
on everything
everything it makes no sense
it makes no sense james
it's crazy
yikes that's crazy
anyway
um okay you said you had a question for
me right yeah we'll do the next one okay
fine okay cool let's do am i the [ __ ]
there okay
so
um this is like a nice little throwback
okay that's kind of long actually right
so this is like a throwback so for
people who don't know
obviously with the um of the [ __ ]
you guys send us in the um the [ __ ]
we read them out and we conclude and
give you guys the feedback
back in the day
before anyone used to watch this show
no one used to send us [ __ ] don't send
us a thing
we would beg people to send us some
other [ __ ] no one would ever send
them in uh because there was no one to
send them in yeah it was literally it
was me and james yeah there was two
viewers and they were us
um
but someone recently said what um we
used to get them from reddit
um [ __ ] i forgot i used to get them
from reddit i forgot about we had
nowhere else to get them from so the
first ever am i the [ __ ] were from
reddit and um
someone
has uh
slid in our dms and i was like oh i know
you guys only do fan read uh or fans
submitted i'm on the arseholes but
here's one from reddit that his one from
reddit i think is really good
and uh
me being mr nostalgic i was like [ __ ]
read it and i even forgot i was like
[ __ ] read it that's where it all started
so far [ __ ] it let's go back to reddit
pause
do you think reddit is called ready
because when you read it you've read it
i don't know
ah maybe
that legend came to mind but anyway but
it's not spelt like that i know it's not
spelled like that but obviously yeah
maybe i don't know
red is a dark place man there's trolls
on reddit they don't want anyone to be
happy
anyway right am i the [ __ ] okay
so my daughter steffy just turned nine
on saturday she's been asking for a
switch for a while now
and i think she's gone old enough and
mature enough that i can trust her with
a big present like that
so the plan was to give steffy's
give steffy the switch at her birthday
party which was the same day however
that ended up falling through we ended
up not being able to pick up the switch
until sunday morning
see steffy was invited to her classmate
jolene's party on sunday so i figured
that since we were still in the party
spirit i would just give steffy the
switch after cake at jolene's party
interesting
hmm
you don't really run your kid a present
at someone else someone else's party is
a bit of a piss take yeah
and she had a party yesterday yes like
proposing at someone else's wedding yeah
yeah yeah why are you trying to steal
the thunder man you had your party
yesterday why are you trying to bring
these vibes over here yeah yeah right
nothing more than that yeah so
just the unwrapping and then the
spotlight will be right back on jolene
hmm i can see this is already going
where we think it's going besides the
girls are friends so i couldn't i would
add
so i figured it wouldn't be a big deal
see we already caught where this was
going
they're nine they're old enough to
understand uh this was an
extenuating circumstance
then this is sometimes what i hate about
my [ __ ] right people say am i the
[ __ ] but then they try and justify
their own actions so much to make it
seem like they're not the [ __ ] before
people make the decision
right
everything went as i had planned and i
thought it went well but after the party
was over i got a call from jolene's mum
essentially asking me what the hell i
was thinking rugs that i was undermining
her because she couldn't afford
something like a switch for jolene yikes
correct me if i'm wrong but i have not
raised steffy to even really care about
the things like how much a present cost
also jolin didn't even care because she
had numerous new things to play with as
defy shared her switch with her so it
seems to me like everyone made out well
jolene's mum also called me petty and a
show-off
in brackets she and i do not like one
another and i won't sugarcoat it
but i put that aside for the kids
because our issues aren't their fault
which jolene's mom is definitely not
doing
husband says he gets where i was coming
from but maybe should have at least
waited until after jolene's presence
were opened so she could have hers first
that's fair but i'm not sure if that
quite makes me uh an [ __ ] to joleen
am i the [ __ ]
yes yeah 100 yes yes 100 yes 10
yes there's no way in hell you should be
giving your daughter a present at
someone else's birthday party when
you've just had yours the day before
regardless of what's happened regardless
of the fact that you weren't able to
give it to her on the day or blah blah
blah
you can wait for any other day you could
have waited till she got back home 100
wait until she got given it to her
before she went to the party something
you know 100 other options there are
other options don't take the piss like
that absolute piss don't take the piss
like that this is someone else's
daughter's ninth i'm assuming on her
10th birthday bro they're gassed
the spotlight is on them yeah your
daughter had her spot like yesterday she
had a party yesterday that's the thing
as well maybe it might have been
justified if her party was [ __ ] two
weeks ago or like when i don't even know
when or whatever bro but literally like
her birthday was yesterday
since we're stood in the party spirit
let me just bring this present to
another girl's birthday
whilst she's opening presents said oh
sorry guys i've just got one more
present for my daughter and it's not
only just one more present it's the
biggest present she's ever had a
nintendo switch a nintendo switch in
which this girl has not got
i could understand if she had a nintendo
switch yeah yeah i said
good point
i'm glad you got that because we
actually got
my girl steffi uh switch as well and
since she's opened hers steffi you might
as well have yours we were gonna wait
till we got home but since you've got
one you guys can play together here's
yours yeah yeah yeah that would have
been orchestrated well orchestrated
everyone's happy
piss take
absolute [ __ ] piss take place
absolute [ __ ] piss take am i the
[ __ ]
of course the mama's going to bail you
of course the mum was going to buy you
like what the [ __ ] do you think you're
doing bro undermining why couldn't you
wait till we got you got home
why 100 percent well dora's trying to
open our presents what the [ __ ] are you
even doing bringing a present here
what the [ __ ] are you doing you're not
bringing presents for my daughter why
are you bringing a present
exactly right are you bringing a present
to my next man party that doesn't belong
to the celebrity dude why couldn't it
wait till you got home it's literally
doesn't make sense why the [ __ ] couldn't
it wait till you got home it baffles me
yeah you're a [ __ ] brother
you wanted the spotlight or you wanted
your daughter to have the spot 100 and
this whole oh
they're nine they don't think i didn't
raise steffi to think about how much it
cost trust me she knows how much [ __ ]
costs at nine she knows exactly how much
[ __ ] cost she is stupid bro [ __ ] [ __ ]
stupid oh you messed up there yeah you
done [ __ ] up and of course jolene's
gonna be like oh i wish i got a switch
or whatever like of course
oh it was fine they were sharing
big man jordan shared it for ten minutes
and was a vex that she ain't got one
myself give me back my switch yeah
yeah whatever man you're a [ __ ] yeah
open and sharp but yeah anyway guys
happy monday we love you
uh those of you who came out for the bbe
thank you very much we appreciate you we
appreciate you
um and yeah man catch you guys on
thursday yeah man gang bless love love
[Music]